le corps du dictateur documentaire
réalisé par José Bourgarel Mussolini
Hitler Staline Franco Pinochet Saddam
Hussein comment sont-ils morts qu'elle
sort a-t-il été réservé à leur dépouille
et dans quel but vis-à-vis de la
population une grande partie des
réponses figurées vous venez de le voir
dans ce film et nous allons continuer à
nous interroger maintenant à propos de
l'encombrant de vie post mortem des
dictateurs sur ce plateau de débat doc
avec nos invités José Bourgarel est avec
nous bienvenue à vous c'est donc vous
qui avez réalisé ce documentaire vous
êtes réalisateur documentariste vous
comptez 37 films dans votre filmographie
à ce jour dont le tout dernier
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour le dire il
s'intitule Le Roman de Lula il s'agit de
la vie du président brésilien et nous
aurons l'occasion très bientôt dans
cette même émission de débattoque de
présenter ce qui est donc votre 37e
documentaire mais on va d'abord reparler
de celui-ci que nous venons de voir
évidemment à l'instant on va le faire
avec Marianne Matar Bonucci bienvenue à
vous vous êtes historienne professeur
d'histoire contemporaine à l'université
Paris 8 spécialiste du fascisme italien
et directrice de la revue à l'armée
c'est une revue spécialisée sur les
questions de racisme on vous doit entre
autres ce livre totalitarisme fasciste
ouvrage publié chez CNRS édition et puis
enfin avec nous François Guillaume
Laurent bienvenue et vous êtes romancier
et journaliste à l'hebdomadaire Le Point
où vous traitez de l'histoire et de
questions géopolitiques avec tout
récemment c'est très important en quête
publiée dans votre journal et intitulé
Comment finissent les dictateurs qui se
trouve que c'est le également le sujet
du film que nous venons de voir et c'est
une enquête que vous avez dirigée
chapeauté au sein de cette hebdomadaire
Le Point José Bourgarel pourquoi avoir
fait ce film sur ce sujet qu'est-ce qui
vous a motivé temps de de nationalisme
un petit peu partout de populisme voire
de néofascisme voire de néonazisme et je
me trouvais j'ai trouvé intéressant
d'aller voir ce que devenait le corps de
ces dictateurs qui souvent sont des
lieux de pèlerinage et qui souvent
montrent une corrélation en fait entre
leur succès et la situation politique
actuelle par exemple si on prend
l'Italie et ben on voit que les
pèlerinages sur la tombe de Mussolini
après dafios attire chaque année au
moins 100000 personnes et comme par
hasard c'est là que les néo-facites sont
revenus au pouvoir à l'automne dernier
d'ailleurs au moment où il y a eu
d'énormes manifestations pour les 100
ans de la marche Rome pour fêter enfin
fêter commémorer en tout cas les 100 ans
de la marche Rome comme une souligné a
pris le pouvoir en 1922 et on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a souvent un rapport en fait
entre le traitement du corps de ces
dictateurs et ce qu'il en a déjà ensuite
voilà et donc que ce soit chez nous en
Europe ou que ce soit un peu partout
d'ailleurs autour de la terre et dans
les pays communistes il y a des
similitudes et surtout il y a des
enseignements qu'on peut en tirer pour
aujourd'hui notre propre situation et
précisément la démocratie qui parfois
peut être encore un petit peu mise en
cause et menacée dans certains pays et
il y a souvent un rapport avec ça
qu'est-ce que vous avez le plus surpris
au terme de cette enquête que vous avez
réalisé dans le cadre de ce de ce film
alors que vous ignoriez qui vous ont
vraiment surprise après avoir traité le
sujet ah oui oui il y a des choses que
j'ai découvertes absolument
d'abord ce qui est très étonnant en ce
qui concerne la dictateur communiste
j'ai découvert le transfert de sacralité
en quelque sorte qu'il y a chez les chez
les chez les dictateurs communistes
c'est-à-dire qu'en finir viendra
d'ailleurs ils reprennent finalement
toutes les tous les éléments de la
liturgie religieuse alors que les
systèmes communistes comme on le sait
ont été ancré construits sur un refus
total de la religion or c'est exactement
la même chose c'est très intéressant
j'ai découvert une deuxième chose c'est
que dans les systèmes fascistes là du
coup on arrive souvent à la volonté de
vouloir faire disparaître ces cadavres
avant qu'on brans c'est-à-dire on veut
plus on veut plus avoir affaire à ça on
dit ah non mais ça c'est fini solini
c'était non non c'était pas nous Hitler
terminé non non c'était pas nous et puis
dernière chose que j'ai découvertes
aussi en traitant le l'exemple qui nous
concerne nous deux Pétain en France
c'est que Pétain il y a des images de
Pétain le bras tendu comme on a pu voir
avec Mussolini ou avec Franco et que moi
je n'avais jamais vu ni à l'école ni
dans les manuels voilà donc j'ai
découvert plein de choses en effet et
c'est très instructif alors Mussolini
bien sûr on va commencer par les
dictateurs on va dire historiques
notamment évidemment du 20e siècle
Hitler Staline évoqué dans ce film et
bien sûr
Mussolini Mussolini fusiller le 28 avril
exposé pendu par les pieds ainsi que sa
maîtresse le 29 avril le lendemain donc
sur la Piazzale Loreto c'est à Milan
c'est là que évidemment le fascisme
avait également pris naissance à Milan
et puis ensuite ce corps a été enterré
anonymement dans un cimetière proche de
Milan et ce jusqu'en 1957 avant
d'arriver dans un caveau familial situé
dans la ville vous l'avez dit de
prédation
pourquoi avoir exposé ce corps fusiller
à la toute fin d'avril 45 quel était le
but de ce
documentaire montre bien effectivement à
quel point le corps donc des dictateurs
et la personne du dictateur joue un rôle
dans ses religions politiques
totalitaire et je trouve que de ce point
de vue là la comparaison est
intéressante il y a peut-être une
singularité pour Mussolini qui est que
de tous ces dictateurs c'est celui qui a
le plus exposé son corps le culte de la
personnalité passée pour le corps au
sens le plus charnel du terme Mussolini
se montrer torse nu en train de
moissonner en train de nager
Hitler Staline les autres n'ont pas fait
cela ils étaient dans les habits du
dictateur mais là il y a une corporéité
si je puis dire qui est beaucoup plus
fort du coup les outrages que l'on fait
subir au cadavre du dictateur sont une
réponse aussi à la forme même qu'a pris
ce culte de la personnalité et puis il y
a aussi une haine accumulée parce que le
film on n'est pas rentré dans les
détails alors que ça a été filmé cette
exposition du corps à Piat salé Loretto
là où quelques temps plus tôt on avait
exposé les cadavres de partisans
évidemment le lieu n'a pas été choisi
par hasard et bien ces scènes je veux
dire de
désacralisation précisément de
profanation véritablement ont été en
l'occurrence filmées et ça a été quelque
chose de terrible alors vous disiez le
corps en effet après disparaît il va
être enterré dans des abbayes même la
vue encombrants
Hitler on va venir dans un instant oui
alors même la veuve ne sait pas où il
est en l'occurrence et ce n'est qu'en
1957 c'est-à-dire probablement un moment
où la République considère qu'elle est
suffisamment solide que effectivement il
est rendu et qu'il peut réintégrer cette
sépulture familiale qui est un mausolée
un véritable mausolée après dapio en
effet alors juste un détail puisque je
crois me souvenir que ça n'apparaît pas
dans le dans le film et qui est
intéressant c'est que bon le corps a
bien évidemment été autopsie après et le
cerveau a été prélevé mis dans du formol
analyser envoyer aux Américains parce
qu'on se demandait si le cerveau d'un
dictateur était un cerveau ordinaire et
les analyses ont montré que
malheureusement sans doute il l'était
mais je crois que c'est un détail qui
est aussi signifiant alors Johan
Chapoutot parle d'une forme de plus
prudence Hitler
il s'est donné la mort au lendemain
de l'exposition en place publique du
corps de Mussolini pendu par les pieds
et s'il semble-t-il ce qui a convaincu
Hitler de mettre fin à ses jours dans le
bunker une jurisprudence Hitler est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça sur le
recul qu'on peut en avoir aujourd'hui
se donner la mort justement parce que on
n'a pas envie d'être exposé en public on
n'a pas envie de finir dans une cage de
fauve comme disait Hitler en défilant
sur la place rouge ce qui est certain
c'est que Hitler a suivi très très près
ce qui se passait en Italie et donc il
en a tirait tout de suite les leçons et
pour revenir à Mussolini je crois qu'il
y a aussi une autre jurisprudence qui va
valoir dans beaucoup de cas de
disparition dictateur c'est montrer tout
simplement la mort au peuple certifié
qu'en fait la le corps
et que la mort a bien eu lieu et éviter
toutes les légendes les complots sur sur
tout ce qui peut
sur une éventuelle deuxième vie
survie de ce dictateur qui va avoir lieu
d'ailleurs avec Hitler parce que on n'a
pas vu le corps parce qu'il a été brûlé
et c'est vrai que en fait c'est une mise
en scène qui répond à une autre mise en
scène et vous avez raison de dire qu'en
fait bon Mussolini c'est le corps
virilisé c'est le corps montrer exhibé
donc d'autant plus profané d'autant plus
souillé et curieusement Hitler qui
n'avait pas de corps lui il n'hésite pas
alors que Mussolini il a pensé aussi à
se suicider dans les quelques jours il y
a eu des choses qui ont circulé dans sa
dans sa tête dont dont aussi
éventuellement le suicide tandis Hitler
finalement et curieusement on voit bien
que la dictature et ça on va le
retrouver avec Staline avec la dictature
en fait se retourne contre son dictateur
et qu'est-ce qui arrive curieusement à
Hitler il demande à brûler son corps or
qu'est-ce que c'est que la dictature
nazi essentiellement c'est quand même
une dictature qui n'a pas cessé
d'exterminer en brûlant des corps c'est
quand même très frappant
et donc oui il y a une il y a une
jurisprudence et claire mais
est-ce que après moi une jurisprudence
c'est quelque chose qui va être reprise
le suicide des dictateurs ensuite n'est
pas désolé mais c'est pas repris donc
moi je suis pas trop chapouteux là
dessus c'est pas il va y avoir des
procès il va y avoir des trains qui va y
avoir plein de choses des exils mais pas
de souci par contre j'irai plus une
jurisprudence Mussolini pour Hitler
non je crois que c'est important ce qui
vient d'être dit c'est à dire que il y a
quelque chose de paradoxal chez mais en
même temps d'assez d'assée signifiant
chez ce dictateur
le national socialiste de tous les
totalitarisme enfin avoir avec le
stalinisme a été l'un des plus abouties
et il va jusqu'à contrôler sa mort et
jusqu'à la contrôler effectivement
de la manière en éliminant son corps ça
je crois que c'est très important comme
il a cherché à éliminer effectivement
les corps de ce qu'il considéraient
comme étant ses adversaires par
excellence en l'occurrence les Juifs et
donc là en effet il y a une singularité
je crois absolue dans la façon dont
Hitler disparaît et toute la supercherie
la mise en scène qui va être de courte
durée des Soviétiques cherchant
justement à trouver un corps pour
montrer effectivement qu'on l'a eu et je
l'ai bien mort prouve à quel point pour
mettre un terme un processus historique
l'exhibition du corps du vaincu est en
effet quelque chose de très important
tout l'enjeu finalement c'est de
désacraliser un dictateur mais alors
c'est très inscrit avec Hitler là en
plus avec l'exemple de Hitler ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que les Russes
une fois qu'ils se rendent compte que ça
marche pas du tout leur histoire de
Sosie là ils ont trouvé un gars qui
ressemble vachement Chrysler une fois
qu'ils se rendent compte que ça marche
pas du tout à ce moment là Staline
laisse planer le doute
où est son corps on sait pas trop et
puis il y a des théories fumeuses qui
commencent à apparaître ce serait parti
en Amérique du Sud il serait parti si
voilà et finalement ça le sert bien
c'est à dire que Staline se dit on va
laisser sa planer et comme ça on va
pouvoir nous dire attention il faut
rester très très prudent il faut rester
sur le coup et donc le communisme doit
être défendu voilà et donc il change de
pied et c'est très intéressant c'est à
dire que le cadavre présent il décide
d'une d'une
conduite à avoir le cadavre qui n'est
plus là on va on va changer mon dossier
de s'en servir aussi pardon non je sais
que Toulon jeu était de désacraliser
c'est ce que vous dites aussi d'ailleurs
dans votre
en fait la mort du dictateur c'est un
renversement complet absolu de ce que la
dictature a mis en place
c'est un peu comme dans un carnaval en
fait un carnaval macabre évidemment mais
un carnaval où on voit les pulsions
aussi se défouler un peuple qui a été
opprimé et qui peut répondre d'où la
violence et c'est vrai que ce carnaval
il a jamais pouvez aussi plus frappant
qu'avec Mussolini parce que il y a accès
en fait il y a aussi quelque chose de
l'ordre de la
vous disiez profanation en effet il y a
quelque chose on a on touche on peut
marteler on peut renverser vous savez le
dictateur on regarde toujours dans en
contre-plongée or ce qui est frappant
sur les plans sur mes souligné par
exemple c'est qu'on au contraire là on
peut être au dessus de comme avec la
mort sur chaosescu les derniers plantes
dans la dans la caserne c'est un plan
au-dessus plonger on domine le dictateur
et ça je crois que dans l'inconscient
c'est extrêmement important alors que
faire d'un cadavre que faire du corps
d'un dictateur c'est tout le sujet et
vous disiez tout à l'heure ce que vous
avez peut-être surpris à l'occasion de
cette enquête c'est l'exemple communiste
on va dire où là il s'agit au contraire
de sacraliser l'État par le corps de son
chef alors c'était vrai pour
Lénine bien entendu mais surtout pour
Staline qui est lui a été érigé au camp
des dictateurs évidemment c'est aussi
vrai pour d'ailleurs cumulsum du côté de
la Corée du Nord
au chiminnes Mao ils ont tous un
mausolée et dans cette idée de capter
l'héritage aussi pour pour ceux qui
suivent l'Italie était évidemment auprès
du corps de Lénine et trosky lui n'y
étais pas par exemple
alors Staline ça s'est retourné contre
lui d'ailleurs parce que il a voulu donc
se faire enterrer à côté de Lénine et
puis une fois que le rapport coût de
chef est arrivé en 61 on a enlevé son
corps très discrètement dans la nuit de
nuit dans l'anonymat voilà donc
c'est-à-dire que le glissement on va
dire qu'il y avait eu lieu où Staline
avait réussi à capter en quelque sorte
l'héritage de Lénine pendant de son
vivant bah ça a pas durer très longtemps
parce qu'après le destinalisation là du
coup son corps a servi aussi de messages
politiques de la part du politique
bureau en disant regardez si on enlève
le corps de Staline c'est la preuve que
nous rentrons dans une période de
destinée de destinylisation voilà mais
sinon fait des communistes il y a aussi
un autre exemple qui est très
intéressant c'est Mao quand même c'est
que Mao il est toujours quand même
aujourd'hui sur la Place Rouge et il est
toujours au fondement même du pouvoir
communiste en Chine alors après faut
qu'il encore parler de communiste parce
que c'est un peu un mélange de
communisme capitalisme mais en tout cas
le la dépouille de Mao est toujours très
très importantes pour le pouvoir
aujourd'hui en Chine sachant qu'on est
donc c'était 76 on est quand même
pratiquement 50 ans après sa mort mais
c'est marrant parce que vous savez le
médecin personnel de Mao raconte dans
ses mémoires une histoire intéressante
il raconte que quand Mao est mort on est
venu le chercher chez lui en pleine nuit
pour aller faire l'embaumement voilà et
là lui c'est c'est ses collègues
médecins en baumeur légiste etc le parti
leur a dit je vous préviens si vous
ratez l'abonnement vous êtes tous morts
et donc ils étaient tellement terrorisés
que quand en fait ils ont injecté le
formol dans le corps ils en ont mis trop
et donc ça veut dire que le corps de Mao
a commencé à gonfler comme ça ils sont
dit ouh là là ouh là là qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire et finalement ils ont réussi
derrière à couper le costume pour que ça
ne se voit pas et là ils sont dit ouf
nous sommes sauvés mais ils ont eu très
peur de tout disparaître des uns les
autres parce que c'était extrêmement
important de pouvoir montrer ce corps
rapidement à la terre entière demeure
alors question est-ce que pour
désacraliser
un dictateur une fois qu'il est mort
ce qu'il faut que le corps est disparu
ou est-ce qu'il faut parce que l'exemple
de Mussolini en la matière
laisse songeur c'est il y a des
commémorations trois fois par an par
exemple il y a des commémorations
il y a des commémorations qui sont le
fait de cette fameuse les restes de
Mussolini oui des commémorations qui
sont le fait de nostalgie qui n'ont
strictement rien de d'officiel en
l'occurrence
je pense que la question n'est peut-être
pas le corps mais et peut-être justement
le procès il faut rappeler quand même
que les Américains voulaient durée
Mussolini pour faire un procès qu'il y a
eu un certain nombre de Procé à
Nuremberg notamment d'un certain nombre
de dignes terre nazis et que les procès
sont jusqu'à nouvel ordre la meilleure
façon peut-être d'infliger une forme de
désacralisation au potentiel au
dictateur ce que je voulais dire c'est
que ce documentaire est très intéressant
touche à quantité donc de sujets de
domaine de l'histoire et à peut-être un
petit peu tendance àplanir une
différence qui de mon point de vue et
est importante puisqu'on parlait de
Staline qui est celle entre l'univers
des totalitarismes fascistes et du
socialisme parce que ce qu'on voit bien
aussi bien dans le cas de Mao
précisément que de Lénine Staline c'est
que le corps reste quand même il est
vénéré alors effectivement il est mis à
l'écart dans le contexte de la
déstabilisation mais parce que
l'adéquation entre l'idée et le corps
l'idée le socialisme qui a précédé quand
même le culte des chefs là ne disparaît
pas et là je crois qu'il y a quand même
une une différence assez fondamentale
c'est que les fascistes sont vraiment
incarnés dans la personnalité des
dictateurs alors que les choses sont
quand même plus complexes je crois dans
dans le cas des socialistes en
l'occurrence
de vous dire que ni les ni Mao ne
souhaitait être embaumé les deux avaient
dit surtout pas c'est contre les
enseignements du marxisme pur donc on
l'a fait cet effet contre leur volonté
en quelque sorte est-ce qu'on peut
peut-être juste une incise rajoutée
c'est que cette question du corps en
politique elle dépasse aussi largement
le monde des dictateurs voyez le
Panthéon je veux dire voyez là toute la
statuaire l'histoire est faite de cela
c'est à dire que les idées politiques
effectivement sont portées sont incarnés
par des hommes et reste à savoir après
comment on transforme l'incarnation en
idée justement on voit bien que le corps
des dictateurs est embarrassant c'est un
peu comme ça il y a une pièce de UNESCO
qui s'appelle Amédée ou comment s'en
débarrasser en le dictateur on commence
à débarrasser et
la plus récemment avec Kadhafi avec
Saddam Hussein
Kadhafi on l'a exposé pendant deux trois
jours après sa mort à cirte on a fait
défiler toutes les huiles du pays pour
s'assurer leur montrer qu'il était bien
mort pour voilà montrer la victoire mais
ensuite quelqu'un
des rebelles est venu a pris le corps et
parti dans le désert et on ne sait
toujours pas où et
enterrer
bien terrain incognita
idem avait avec Saddam Hussein on l'a un
moment rendu à la famille en toute
discrétion les Américains ont repris le
corps aux Irakiens
acquises avaient demandé de l'exécuter
après à la fin du procès et puis quand
daesh est arrivé en 2015 là on a fait de
nouveau disparaître parce que la famille
a compris que le corps était en et donc
voilà on ne sait plus donc il y a une
sorte de volatilisation mais je voulais
revenir sur non mais ça rejoint ma
question c'est à dire que Mussolini
aujourd'hui sont forts il est toujours
présents
de l'extrême droite italienne tout
simplement parce que ce corps existe
cette mémoire existe aux yeux de tous
les Italiens aujourd'hui contrairement à
Saddam Hussein ou moi marcadhafi dont le
corps n'existe plus on y fait encore
référence
faut pas trop lui prêter de pouvoir mais
en revenant sur Mao il y a quelque chose
aussi de où on voit que les dictateurs
instaure la crainte du corps vivant et
du corps mort à la fois une crainte
terrible c'est que
les Chinois n'avaient pas envisagé la
mort de Mao c'est-à-dire que le corps au
départ du dictateur est immortel
et quand il quand il est mort il se sont
retrouvés ils avaient pas pensé non plus
au funérailles puisqu'on vous pensez pas
la mort vous pensez pas vous funérailles
et donc ils sont dit mais comment on
fait donc il faut aller voir ils ont
essayé d'aller voir les Russes s'ils
avaient un exemple en effet vous avez
raison on sacrase chez les communistes
mais il y avait plus de relation
sino-soviétique ils étaient embêté donc
ils sont allés voir au chiminent
au Vietnam mais là les Vietnamiens on
vous dites non non mais on vous dit rien
et c'est pour ça c'est devenu un
casse-tête incroyable mais à cause de
quoi à cause de l'impenser en fait
l'impossibilité de penser la mort du
dictateur ça c'est quand même aussi les
dictateurs eux-mêmes ils y pensent à
leur mort la preuve Franco par exemple
créer un mémorial
où on enterre à la fois d'ailleurs les
partisans et et et ceux qui ne sont pas
de Franco il veut il voulait en faire un
lieu de mémoire certains dictateurs de
leur on envisageait leur mort et la
manière dont leur corps
devaient survivre l'exemple de Franco
est très intéressant parce que Franco a
été très malin justement en faisant
enterré avec lui et à la fois des
partisans et à la fois des fascistes et
donc ça a été une des raisons de la
difficulté de régler ce problème puisque
en 2019 le gouvernement espagnol
finalement a réussi à faire enlever le
corps de Franco du mausolée de l'oscaido
et qu'il souhaite inhumés dans une
sépulture familiale mais ça a été un
combat politique épique très très
important donc oui il y en a qui ont
pensé oui on a oublié parce que c'était
il y a plus presque 50 ans mais l'agonie
de Franco était presque un des premiers
feuilletons médiatique du 20e siècle
voilà je donne mon corps à l'Espagne
regardez les dernières semaines ça n'en
finit pas chaque jour les Espagnols
regardaient leur journal ce qu'il est
mort est-ce qu'il est pas mort donc là
il y a une mise en scène de la sortie et
de dans un pays extrêmement catholique
presque vraiment le Christ et la
crucifixion mais une auto crucifixion
presque
donc il y a presque une utilisation
presque cynique de de sa propre mort qui
est très étonnante et qui est assez rare
dans le il y a d'ailleurs une croix de
30 mètres de haut au dessus de au-dessus
du Moselle il y en a d'autres il y en a
d'autres qui l'utilisent en pour
échapper souvent on constate que les
dictateurs sont très souvent très très
malade curieusement pour échapper
jusqu'ici Pinochet
au Necker en Allemagne aussi en
Allemagne de l'Est ils ont eu
curieusement beaucoup de séjour en
hôpitaux et ça leur a permis quand même
de survivre c'est-à-dire là aussi c'est
une autre manière de mettre en scène son
corps c'est c'est dire regarder je suis
vraiment au bout du rouleau
ayez pitié de moi et et parfois ça
marche on va voir un extrait du
documentaire je
qui nous parle de l'exil il y trouve une
belle solution pour se débarrasser du
corps d'un dictateur qui est pas encore
mort
on se rend compte dans le long terme de
l'histoire
en l'occurrence si on se limite au 19e
21e et 28e siècle que la meilleure
manière de de s'occuper ou d'une plus
occuper plutôt du de la personne et du
corps du dictateur c'est c'est l'exil
dans les circonstances de l'exil hors de
leur carte de référence
ils sont rendus au fond pour reprendre
les termes de Bossuet ils sont rendus au
destin de toute chair c'est-à-dire que
ils ne sont plus rien
alors je vais en citer quelques-uns des
dictateurs qu'on choisit l'exil ou parce
que le régime en place on choisit les
exilés le chat d'Iran Ben Ali aminda
jean-benel boucassa Jean-Claude Duvalier
évidemment pour Haïti et Mobutu pour le
Zaïre c'est la meilleure solution l'exil
oui enfin ça prouve bien quand même que
c'est toujours un problème et que c'est
toujours une menace parce que Mobutu il
est toujours au Maroc et donc si
aujourd'hui après tant d'années passées
ça dépouille n'est pas rapatriée alors
que ça de sa famille le demande depuis
cette époque là c'est que ça représente
toujours à une menace pour le pouvoir en
place voilà donc c'est une solution oui
pour le nouveau pouvoir en effet voilà
mais c'est une solution alors est-ce que
c'est une solution pérenne je ne sais
pas Mobutu restera peut-être habitable
là-bas
[Musique]
de refiler la patate chaude à d'autres
pays c'est une tradition qui a commencé
intéressante avec avec True rhylo en
Saint-Domingue dans les années 50 qui
s'est fait une spécialité de recueillir
chez lui les dictateurs sud-américains
qui avaient des problèmes ils disent
venez il crée une sorte d'international
des dictateurs déchus chez vous chez
nous on sera bien traité et après on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait des
terres d'asile des pays refuges c'était
d'abord la France a beaucoup dans sa
tradition
modèle
africains puis c'était le Maroc vous
voulez citer aujourd'hui c'est l'Arabie
Saoudite avec des alors on peut on peut
on peut se demander voilà il y a des
sortes d'empathie de de synergie
d'esprit entre ces pays
qui classe alors la Corée du Nord n'a
jamais encore
accueilli de dictateur mais bon pour
elle pourrait le faire
tous les le sujet à la fin il y a le
corps du dictateur et il y a l'idée à
mon avis
parce que là on parle pas de corps
toujours vivants l'exil permet qu'un
dictateur meurt loin de la terre qui la
portait qu'il l'a chéri mais la question
est de savoir ce qu'il reste après ce
qui reste des partisans est-ce qu'il
reste des idées et donc je pense que
pour ce qui est du fascisme italien du
national socialiste ou même du
franquisme il y a encore aujourd'hui des
nostalgiques qui s'appuient sur des
textes qui s'appuient sur l'histoire
tout simplement une histoire qui peut
être incarnée ou pas et qui représente
un danger pour la démocratie
indépendamment du corps même si c'est le
sujet en l'occurrence du documentaire et
d'aujourd'hui donc le corps c'est
important mais le corps n'est pas tout
précisément me semble-t-il
et vous dites le corps indicateur n'a
jamais une mort comme comme tout à
chacun comme les autres c'est toujours
extraordinaire la mort d'un dictateur
qu'est-ce qui vous fait dire ça c'est
toujours extraordinaire parce que les
morts dans son lit à 91 ans oui certes
mais il y a toujours un ange c'est à
dire que la mort d'un dictateur et le
devenir de son enveloppe corporelle de
toute façon est toujours un problème
Pinochet est mort dans son lit certes
mais ça veuve a demandé à ce qu'il
souhaite incinérer pour que surtout il
n'y ait pas de sépultures parce que elle
elle avait elle craignait en revanche
que la sépulture soit profane et donc là
c'est pas qu'on avait peur que ce soit
un lieu de recueillement de ces
partisans c'est qu'elle avait peur que
ça s'est culture soit profane et
d'ailleurs ce qui est rigolo c'est que
Pinochet c'est cendres ont été dispersés
dans sa propriété et puis finalement la
propriété a été abandonnée et finalement
il y a des squatteurs qui sont venus et
qu'on fait pousser de la marijuana
figurez-vous dans ce jardin
dans sa tombe qui n'est pas une tombe
pour ce qui est de vider là en Argentine
ce sont carrément les habitants du
village natal de villa qui sont opposés
au retour de de son de sa dépouille
voilà donc c'est très compliqué c'est
très compliqué en terme de pouvoir c'est
très compliqué pour la famille c'est
très compliqué pour tout le monde en
fait voilà et alors de votre et on
finira là-dessus dans votre enquête
longue enquête un hebdomadaire le point
il y a aussi la question des avoir à
l'étranger des dictateurs et on se rend
compte qu'il est très très difficile de
remettre la main sur les avoir détenus
par l'éducateurs qui sont décédés je
vais en citer quelques-uns Jean-Claude
Duvalier avait 300 millions de dollars à
l'extérieur Benali entre 5 et 9
milliards d'euros
Sanya Bacha ça c'est pour le Nigéria
avait lui aussi énormément d'argent à
l'extérieur de son pays ça se compte là
aussi en milliards d'euros
Marcos Ferdinand Marcos sa femme 10
milliards de dollars Mobutu Zaïre 11
milliards de dollars
et enfin Mubarak si j'en crois votre
enquête et celui qui avait le plus de
d'avoir à l'extérieur 40 milliards de
dollars il est très difficile pour les
états de remettre la main c'est les
avoir des dictateurs il y a une
difficulté à déterminer à fixer le
lavoir les sommes sont très
approximatives de en fait c'est
dictateurs prennent énormément de
précaution et il y a multitude de
prêtres non de société écran des
montages financiers en plus finir c'est
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles il
y a une difficulté à remettre la main
sur cet argent après il y a des
difficultés juridiques entre les les
pays d'origine ou les dictateurs
régnaient et les multiples paradis fixés
ou c'est parce qu'on évoquait par
exemple l'exil tout à l'heure on se rend
compte que parmi ces dictateurs certains
négocier en Arabie Saoudite intouchables
même au fait de leur pouvoir ils ont ils
pas prévu la chute
où ils ont négocié leur sortie je
stressener par exemple Paraguay est
parti au Brésil mais après une on
l'avait on l'avait menacé d'exécution on
connaît mal en fait les négociations
mais on sait qu'il est parti ça c'est
avec des millions et des millions de
dollars au Brésil donc il y a un esprit
prévoyant du dictateur
qui peut lui assurer aussi des des jours
heureux et une fin heureuse et un corps
cajolé et Mussolini on finira là-dessus
dans sa cavale des derniers jours il y
avait un butin également
on ne sait pas ce qu'il est devenu en
l'occurrence donc
voilà en revanche le leg du fascisme est
présent partout en Italie indépendamment
du corps ça je crois que c'est important
aussi de le dire notamment à travers
l'architecture donc les lieux outre
prédats le mausolée de prédats les lieux
où sont susceptibles de se retrouver les
nostalgiques ne manque pas l'important
après c'est de faire l'histoire je crois
de ces lieux y compris d'ailleurs du
mausolée merci c'est la fin de cette
émission un grand merci donc à tous les
trois spécialement merci à vous je
faisais Bourgarel pour le film qui nous
a fait découvrir en savoir un peu plus
sur le devenir de ces fameux cadavres de
dictateur et dont nous avons pu nous
entretenir ensuite sur sur ce plateau je
rappelle que très vite très bientôt
maintenant dans cette même émission un
autre de vos films sera la fiche de
débat doc il s'agira de du roman de Lula
on saura tout sur ce qu'est la carrière
ce qui a été la carrière extraordinaire
de l'actuel président brésilien vos
réactions à cette émission ça sera sur
hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter merci
aussi à sel massali qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission et puis moi je vous donne
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
avec bien sûr sans documentaire et son
débat à bientôt
[Musique]